but you're always writing new stuff you
always have new material right you don't
write i don't i i just do it on stage it
doesn't work for me
and i'm lazy
bill burr is one of comedy's most
prolific writers and he's too lazy to
write jokes i'm going to share with you
bill burr's top three favorite writing
techniques and see how many times they
work on making my dog laugh
he's thrilled i've been a comedian 12
years and interviewed over 400 comedians
on this channel and everyone has a
different writing process so what makes
bill burr so special he doesn't write he
riffs so when you say you don't write uh
but you must like make notes to yourself
if you think of something well if i if i
think of something i it's uh i just grab
whatever i can write on and i'll just
write down bear circus and then i do
that and then i just go up and i uh and
i just tell the story yeah so i just act
like you know like you're just gonna go
meet your friends at a bar you just
start shooting the [ __ ] with them so
it's it stops being like hey have you
seen these gorillas doing sign language
what you know what's up with that
riffing is the style of writing that
makes anyone think they can do comedy
but just like anything else you have to
learn the rules before you break them
and bill burr has honed this style over
decades on stage so real quick for my
comedy nerds what is a joke at a
formulaic level a joke is a setup and a
punchline the setup is setting up the
audience to think in one direction and
the punch line creates a surprising
second direction or a misdirect and it's
this surprise that triggers the laughter
so in bill burr's case one of his
favorite ways to create that surprise is
the technique of analogy or
comparison if you don't have a liberal
arts degree like me after hearing on
oprah that mothers have the hardest jobs
in the world bill uses the analogy
technique to compare motherhood to some
of the world's hardest jobs
ober brings out this guest she gives her
this huge intro she's been on this she's
been on that and she does the most
difficult job on the planet she's the
mother
so immediately i look at my girlfriend
i'm like really
being a mom is the most difficult job on
the planet
how many mothers died on ice road
truckers last season
what makes bill burr one of the best is
he hits a topic from every angle most
comics would leave it at two analogies
but he doubles down to drive the point
home another one of bill burr's favorite
techniques are act outs
act out it's when he acts out the joke
come on dog what makes bill burr so
special is not just how he tells a joke
but how he shows a joke look i'm messing
around but you know come on
i know it's a difficult job but the most
difficult job on the whole planet
remember when saddam let the oil fields
on fire and those poor bastards had to
go put them out
4 000 degrees
walking in with your little asbestos
shield just walking in the flames
you want to do that or watch bob the
builder again i mean be honest with
yourself if you're enjoying this video
so far hit that subscribe button to get
access to 400 plus comedy interviews and
our three weekly live streams and now
bill burr's third and final favorite
writing technique double on
in this clip he takes the word rescue
and runs with it most people hear rescue
dog and assume a heartwarming adoption
but not bill burr i got a dog recently
i did i went down to the pound i got one
of those free dogs
yeah that's how i say it i don't say i
rescued a dog
i hate when people say that it's like
totally obnoxious it's complete
exaggeration
she's a rescue yeah i ask eater
really did you pull her out of a burning
building
did you jump in a river with your
clothes still on with no concern for
your own safety or did you just go down
to the pound and get a free dog isn't
that what you did
stop acting like you had to take out a
couple of guards
crawling on your elbows using hand
signals
dude you ever go down to the pound that
they're just giving them
away they don't even do a background
check you want them hey get out of here
who's next you want a poodle come on you
got a perm it'll be hilarious
bilber's brilliance is in not taking any
information at face value what most
people hear and take for granted bill
burr finds a funny twist and just
hammers the humor home which is what
makes him one of the greats this episode
was inspired by comedian yoshi so after
seeing our interview with the joke
doctor talking about bill burke comment
below with comics you want to hear us
break down on this show and subscribe to
check out our 400 plus comedy interviews
subscribe
so my wife doesn't make me get a real
job